too.
Ultimately, what we talk about in terms
of the machine economy can only be made
possible by what we define as being the
internet of economics, which the
Gajumaru delivers.
The The economy that we talk about now,
when you see people talking about the
machine economy in in LinkedIn and X,
they have no idea. And if they do have
an idea,
they're probably crypto people, because
crypto people, I think, do know the lies
they're telling. Certainly, anybody
who's ever talked about zero knowledge
proofs that comes from a zero knowledge
proofs lab knows that the mathematical
impossibility of what they're doing or
or they're blind. There's no way that
somebody with the intelligence to get a
job in a place like that doesn't know
the basic maths that under under
completely undermine any claim that the
zero knowledge proof works as a scaling
tool.
Um And I forgive me.
The The point is
all of those illusions have now got to
be gone. We have the only answer in the
world for this. If you look at the 2
million people who are using Open Claw,
and that's growing every single day. If
you go to the Discord channel, it's just
a constant flurry of welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome, welcome.
The machine economy is there. It's about
to be unbridled, but it doesn't have the
economic base upon which to operate. It
doesn't have the tool set, and that
dimensional change is away from the era
of digitization of the corporatist model
to the digitalization
and capitalist model that machines will
actually use. The only way there is
through the Gaju Gajumaru Groot state
channels,
grids, the entire apparatus of security
we've put around this.
That's the That's really the the big big
news from our perspective.